The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time, we started
looking in more detail at some
of the statistical basics.
These are the basis for a lot
of the tools and techniques
that we're going to be learning
about throughout the term,
especially things like
statistical process control,
statistical design
of experiments,
robust optimization,
yield modeling, and so on.
And so we're going to pick up
more or less where we left off.
We talked a bit about
the normal distribution.
And what I want to do is talk
a little bit more about a few
of the assumptions and why
it's so common that we use it
for describing some
of the kinds of data
that we looked at last time.
So we went through a
fairly substantial number
of different examples and saw
variation in time, variation
across different
parameter sets, and so on.
Just to remind us, here's
the-- the standard normal
is just a mean centered.
So if we have x as our data,
and we subtract off the mean,
and then normalize to
the standard deviation,
we get a unit normal variable.
It's another random
variable z that
has a distribution that is
marked out in terms of numbers
of standard deviation.
And so this is our
normal distribution.
Some nice properties that
we mentioned last time
are that it only
has two parameters.
So that completely describes the
normal distribution, the mean,
and the variance or
standard deviation.
Other properties are it's
symmetric about the mean.
We actually will use that
property quite a bit in terms
of manipulating
some of the table
values that one would
look up for the proportion
of the distribution that's
out in either of the tail.
So it's perhaps obvious,
but we actually do use that.
We'll come back to that
a little bit later.
But what I wanted to
start with a little bit
is talking a little bit
more about this assumption,
if you dive into it, that we
are using a normal distribution
very often.
And the questions are, why?
And how good of an approximation
is that in most cases?
When can we use it?
When might we be
motivated to use it?
And what we did last time
is we did a couple of things
where we looked at
some of the data.
In particular, we
did histogram--
binning kinds of
plots of variations.
And that would often motivate,
based on a general shape,
that normal distribution
looked appropriate.
One can, I guess, do a
curve fit to the histogram.
Would you ever try to do that?
So imagine that you
actually had, say,
the tops of the bins
for the distribution.
So maybe I had bins like
this, where sometimes I
had these as values--
something like this.
Now, would you actually try
to do a normal distribution
curve fit to that?
In other words,
if you said, what
I'm going to try
to do is minimize
the errors between these points
and the normal distribution,
does that seem like a
reasonable thing to do?
AUDIENCE: It's all driven
by the size of your tails.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there are
some gotchas, certainly,
with any histogram.
The point was that the
shape of this distribution--
if you've ever played
around, especially
with interactive tools, where
you can bin and plot out
distributions, if you were to
change the size of your bins,
you have this
disturbing effect where
the shape of your distribution
sometimes changes a little bit
out from under you.
So if you change the
bins, you may well
end up with something that--
all of a sudden, this one
was low, and now it's high.
And the next one is
a little bit low.
And this one's up here if your
bins are a little bit wider.
So that might be a concern,
but that's actually
not the point that I'm after.
Would you curve fit to this
distribution to fit a normal
to your data?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said
that normal distribution
is described by a standard
deviation of the mean.
So you might as well just take
the mean and standard deviation
of your data.
PROFESSOR: Beautiful.
AUDIENCE: And use that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right, especially-- I
guess the only circumstance
I can imagine where it might
make sense to curve fit
is you didn't have the raw data.
You only had the bins.
That's kind of strange.
I think in most cases,
you would, in fact,
have the raw data.
And then you simply
calculate the mean
and the standard deviation.
Now one thing we want to do and
we'll get to a little bit today
is why that's a
reasonable thing to do--
to actually go in and
calculate the mean
and standard deviation.
Why is that a good estimator
for the true mean and underlying
parameters for this
distribution-- the true meaning
of the true variance?
There's other things you can
do certainly to check and see.
If you had your data,
and you calculated
the mean and standard
deviation, then you
can plot perhaps your Gaussian
on top of that distribution.
And that, I think,
is a reasonable thing
to do as a quick check visually
to see how well it seems
to map, as well as a
quick check that you
had reasonable calculations,
not something strange go wrong
just in your
numerical calculation
of those parameters.
Now there's a couple
of other things
that one can do to check
quickly visually the assumption.
And then there's a couple of
very nice additional tools
that I'll mention here for
either checking assumptions
or visually--
in a little bit more
sophisticated way,
visually or numerically check
a couple of those assumptions.
But one thing you
can certainly do
is look at the
location of your data
and just do a quick comparison
between the percentage of data
that you would expect in
different bands of this data.
And we'll do a little
bit more examples
there so that we know what
percentage of the data
we expect in the plus/minus
1 sigma band, for example,
or what percentage of the data
we would typically expect out
in the 3 sigma
tails of the data.
And so you can do a quick
calculation and comparison
of the percentage of data in
each of these different bands
and see, is that matching
up to what we would expect
from a normal distribution?
This actually gets
very close to the idea
of confidence
intervals that we'll
formalize a little bit more.
Now there's a couple
of additional things
I've listed here.
One is you can look
at the kurtosis
or do a quick calculation
of kurtosis, which
is a higher order
statistical moment
than the mean or the variance.
In fact, if you look at the
definition of the kurtosis,
it's an expectation
of the fourth moment.
Or it is a calculation--
a normalized version
of the fourth moment.
And for a perfectly
normal distribution,
this kurtosis value would be 1.
And then as the distribution
changes its shape,
either gets more peaked
or less peaked following
other distributions, other
common distributions,
then it starts to deviate
substantially from k equals 1.
And in fact, this is
a quick little tool
to use sometimes if you're
not sure, well, number one,
if it's normal.
And number two, if it's not
normal, what distribution might
it follow?
If you look here,
this is a nice plot,
although I didn't
break out what all
of these different
distributions are.
This is just a plot normalized
to standard deviation
of the data of a set of
different distributions.
And the black one here is n.
So this is-- let me do
the black one here, right?
This is the n distribution.
That's our Gaussian
with a kurtosis.
Well, I guess you got to
look a little bit carefully
at the definition.
Actually, I think if I go back
to the previous page, which
is one that Dave had, this
definition for sample data
is essentially, as n gets very
large, this subtracts off 3.
So that I believe
then, in this case,
this kurtosis for a
normal distribution
is actually more like 0.
These two definitions
you might look up.
I'm not sure are
exactly the same.
Rarely would you
actually use this one.
You're going to actually
use this definition, which
basically subtracts off a value.
This goes with the
plot on the next page.
So they are slightly different
definitions, I believe.
So in that case, that's
subtracting off a 3.
For the normal
distribution, it ends up
with a value of about 0.
Now what's nice
is as you get some
of these distribution, such
as the Laplace distribution,
this very peaked one right here,
the kurtosis value goes up.
It's an indication of a
more peaked distribution.
The logistic distribution,
which we might
talk about a little bit later--
it's one that comes up
occasionally with some quality
or discrete kinds
of distributions--
has a kurtosis of 1.2.
And the interesting
one here also
is the uniform
distribution, which is less
sharply peaked than a Gaussian.
And it actually has a negative
kurtosis with that subtraction
of the 3 off it at the end.
So you might find
that as a useful tool.
I've rarely used kurtosis
actually as an indicator.
But I want to mention
it to you because it
is out there as at
least a hint at looking
at some different distributions.
A more useful tool--
yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So there's
two different formulas?
Because--
PROFESSOR: Well--
AUDIENCE: What you said or--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
this is for sample data.
And I think if you were
to actually go in--
I mean, essentially this--
I have not checked this.
This was some definitions
from previous class notes.
I do believe when I did a
quick lookup on what kurtosis
is, I believe this is a
better definition in terms
of actual calculation
formulas that you
can use for calculating it.
This is to give you the sense.
I mean, it's sort
of lurking in here.
You can see the expectation
operation down in here,
and then the normalization
to the standard deviation.
In this case, this has to
be your calculated standard
deviation.
This is the abstracted one.
So if you actually poke around,
you will find in the literature
more than one
definition of kurtosis.
My point was that
this is what I would
use if you want to use the
plot on the next page in terms
of coming up with a number that
might also indicate if there's
a different distribution
that you might look at.
So it's related to
the fourth moment.
A more useful tool--
and this is one that
I actually do use--
is probability or
quantile-quantile plots.
And there's a section in
Montgomery on that, as well
as different toolboxes.
We'll be able to
generate these things.
And so here's an example for
a quantile-quantile plot.
What I've started doing on
the lecture notes on the web
is put up an early
draft as early
as I can for the next couple
of weeks of lecture notes.
But then as I'm
editing and adding in,
I'll have the most
up-to-date one.
So if you've got slides, you may
be missing a couple of these.
If you printed them out before
9:00 or 10:00 PM last night,
I think these got
updated about that time.
So this plot, for
example, was not
in the early draft
of the slides.
And I'll try to indicate
that with a little "draft"
on the web page if they're still
early drafts of the slides.
So what are
quantile-quantile plots?
These are a little bit subtle
in terms of explaining.
So let me try to give
it a shot at explaining.
And then if you have
questions, let me know.
And then normally, it's going to
be generated by your statistics
package.
There are hand ways
to do it, and I'll
refer you to
Montgomery for practice
with actually trying to generate
them if you had to by hand.
But here's the basic idea.
What we're plotting is the
actual data that you've got.
And in the y-axis, you'll be
plotting your data in terms
of normalized distribution.
So you would normalize to the
mean or center to the mean
and then scale it to
your standard deviation.
So think of these as
unit standard deviations.
So you simply find that as
your y location for your data.
Then what you're plotting
on the x-axis is the normal
theoretical--
I'm not sure I'd
use quantiles here--
but your normal theoretical
standard deviation
for that number of data
points that you would have had
and the location for each
of those data points.
So imagine this
is 50 data points.
I'm not sure exactly how
many data points this is.
If you were to
take 50 data points
and draw 50 data points
from a normal distribution
or order them and put them
where you would expect
on a normal distribution,
what you would have is many
more data points near 0.
And as you get further and
further out, 1 out of 50 times
or 1 out of 25 times,
you would expect
to find a data point
about whatever it is--
2, 2.1 standard deviations away.
In other words, if I were to
compare the actual location
of that data point
in terms of its value
within my sample
distribution of 50,
compared to if I just drew
randomly 50 data points,
that would be its location.
Then what I can do is plot
that coordinate for that data.
So what you end up with is
taking all of your data,
if you will.
You sort it from low to high.
And then starting at the
center, in some sense,
you start working
outward from the center,
ordering the data
from the location
of its index in your
sorted data from number
of standard deviations away
from the mean that it would be,
compared to how far
that data point actually
was away from your sample mean.
And what that gives
you, if it were perfect,
and there was not any sort
of noise in your data,
that would give you this
perfect matching line.
Every data point falls where
you would expect it to.
Now in your actual
data, you're going
to see some
deviations from that.
But what this is basically doing
is a compression of your data
or an expansion of your
data out in the tails,
but a compression of
your data near the center
to be able to basically tell
you how closely your data here
is following the
assumed distribution.
And for this case here,
we plotted the location
of 50 data points, assuming
it was a normal distribution.
So that's where my x
values were coming from.
And as you can
see here, the data
pretty much nicely
follows this distribution.
You get a few little things
that look like it's wandering
or trailing off a little bit.
And then you also often
look out here in the tails.
And you find even out here for
over two standard deviations
away, it looks like I've
got pretty good fidelity
to those tails.
I might have values that
are a little bit further
away from the mean
than I might expect
from a normal distribution,
but it's pretty close.
So this is the kind
of plot that you
would expect to see for
data that, in fact, followed
a normal distribution.
All right, so I know
that's confusing.
Are there questions that
people have on what this--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So for each point,
you get the y-axis
by the sampling
value from your data.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And how do you get x?
Do you get it based on
the probability of that,
simply pulling from
your sample distribution
that you referred to the
theoretical normal distribution
with the same probability,
then you get the y--
x-axis?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
very, very close.
So for the y-axis, you've
got it exactly right.
For the x-axis,
what's interesting is
you don't actually use
the values of your data.
You just use its index location
in a sample of the size
that you've got.
In other words, if I
had a million points,
I would look at the lowest.
And I would expect that to be--
in a normal
distribution, I would
look at where the
probability, the number
of standard deviations where
1 out of 500,000 points
is that far away from the mean.
So I would look up the
inverse probability
on a normal
distribution of being--
of where 1 in 5--
500,000-- point-- what?
0.02 to the whatever.
So I basically look on a
tabulated normal probability
plot, going backwards
from where that index--
my smallest point was.
And then I could do
that for every point
in my sample to figure
out what the probability
for its location should
be on the x-axis.
So here's another example.
Maybe this gives you a feel
because these q-q plots--
the quantile-quantile
plots-- can actually
be used with other
distributions as well.
They are not always
q-q norm plots.
They can be applied
to whatever assumed
probability distribution you
might want to investigate.
So here's an example where
we again took the data.
But in this case, the
theoretical quantiles
are actually lining up.
I'm assuming a
normal distribution.
But in this example
that I'm showing here,
the data actually came from--
let me erase.
Let me get rid of all this.
The data actually came from
an exponential distribution.
So this is an example where
I would have assumed things
were coming from a Gaussian.
So this is still for
the normal quantiles.
But with an exponential
and e to the minus
x or an e to the x kind of
distribution, what you end up
with are a lot of
data values that
are much larger, much
further away from the mean,
than you would expect
from a Gaussian.
And you also get a bunch of
data that's much larger than you
would expect from a Gaussian.
So this would be an example
here, where the normal q-q
plot doesn't seem to match up.
It's telling me my
data really is not
following along the
normal distribution line.
Now, I didn't pull a plot.
But one could then
ask the question--
maybe you'd look up kurtosis.
Or maybe you look back
at your data and say,
I think maybe an exponential
distribution is really
what this is following.
How would you plot
that on a q-q norm?
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why doesn't
the line go through 0, 0?
PROFESSOR: This is
a good question.
These don't appear to
be mean-centered to me.
So there's something
weird on the plot.
AUDIENCE: So the line should be
for a normal distribution, not
fitting.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this does not--
I think what has happened
here is these are not quite
mean-centered and
normalized because--
well, so in terms of 0,
0 following on the plot,
that that's not happening.
So I'm a little--
I'm not sure exactly
what's going on there.
AUDIENCE: We need the
closing function taking
the mean of the data et cetera.
It's a conceptual
normal on the data mean.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it should.
And that's what I'm saying,
is this plot I don't think is
correctly mean-centered
because it should then--
0, 0, by definition,
has to fall.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's
what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: No, I was saying you
could take the mean of the data
you send to the normal
that you're plotting
is aligned with that data.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But I'm saying here's my y
data, and my 0 mean is not--
I don't have any negative--
I don't have any data
lower than the mean.
And therefore, that
doesn't make any sense.
So this is not
mean-centered correctly.
AUDIENCE: It looks to me
like the mean of the data
does give us a slightly less
than 1 in the point data,
so that coincides with the mean.
PROFESSOR: But if I
mean-center and scale to 0,
then the mean of my data have--
by definition, that
ought to be at 0, right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
I don't think you're
shifting the data, though.
PROFESSOR: When you mean-center,
yeah, you're shifting.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I think
you're shifting,
but I think conceptually,
you're not shifting the data.
You're shifting the
normal, that you're
saying my might
correspond to the data.
PROFESSOR: No.
In a normal-- in the standard
q-q norm plot, you mean-center.
You actually take your
data, you mean-center it,
you normalize it to the
calculated sample standard
deviation and plot that.
And that does not look like
quite what they've done here.
I think these are
still normalized
to standard
deviation, but I think
it's not quite mean-centered.
But in some sense
that doesn't actually
matter in terms of the data
following along the line.
It's still indicating.
That would just be a shift.
That would be a shift.
AUDIENCE: You said the
data hasn't been normalized
or hasn't been mean-centered.
But if it's an
exponential distribution,
can you still normalize a bit?
PROFESSOR: In this first
use of such a plot,
you would be testing
the question.
Did your data-- you don't know
yet that it's exponential.
You just have data,
and you're testing.
Does it fall on the normal line?
So you would still
follow that procedure.
We'll look at an exponential
distribution in a minute.
And of course, every
distribution has a mean.
So you can always mean-center.
Similarly, every
distribution has a variance
that you can calculate.
The neat thing about the
exponential is the mean
and the variance are the same.
But that's not entering in here.
There's something else weird.
So there's the risk of pulling
a plot off at 9:50 at night.
I hadn't noticed that the--
it doesn't look
correctly mean-centered.
But the additional
point I wanted to make
is I could actually
take this same data.
I could produce a different
plot, not a normal q-q plot,
but an exponential q-q plot.
And if I were doing that, in
that case, what I would do
is take my data, still plot
it hopefully mean-centered,
and then number of
standard deviations away.
But then along this axis, I
would calculate the location
in numbers of
standard deviations
based on the probability of
an exponential distribution,
not based on the probability
of that index location
in a normal distribution.
So I would basically say,
for my 50 data points,
I expect the 25th data
point larger than the mean
to occur in that distribution.
I have to go 2.1 normalized
standard deviations away
in order to get to
that probability.
So that it takes my
same y data, but then it
plots along the line, where
if it really is exponential,
my data should follow along
a 1 to 1 correspondence line.
So you don't often see
the use of these q-q plots
from the perspective of
different distributions,
but you can use them.
What you often will
see is really this.
You'll see q-q norm plots.
And they're lovely plots.
It's a wonderful tool to do--
use-- because you're actually
seeing all of your data.
It's got all of
your actual data.
It's showing you that
it corresponds roughly
to a normal distribution.
It's also giving you
very nice information
about essentially your
variance or standard deviation.
And there are variants of
these plots that you will often
see in the literature,
especially the semiconductor
literature, dealing with large
numbers of samples coming
from different kinds
of measurement.
So for example, if you want
to make contact resistance
measurements for literally
thousands of contacts and very
succinctly present
that data, you
will see families
of q-q norm plots.
So for example, maybe you
did a bunch of contacts
at a particular size.
You would plot them like this.
And then maybe you
had another data set,
where you had attempted to
pattern those contacts slightly
larger, slightly smaller.
And you would often
see then another--
oops, that's not
very straight, is it?
It's meant to be another
underlying set of data.
But you might find your data
looking something like this.
And that kind of plot is
really useful for showing
that there is a mean
shift, a mean difference
between your data.
But also, the variance is
different in the two cases.
Now, exactly what
you're plotting here
might be a little bit different.
You might actually not
plot quite normalized data.
You might actually use it
in an unnormalized fashion.
Here, you might plot this not
in terms of standard deviations,
but rather actual--
keep it in the quantiles
or the probability
of being that far away--
probability of that x--
that's weird.
The probability of that x value.
So for example, you will
often see these kinds
of plots which would show
things like 0.001, 0.01, 0.1, 1,
or something like
that, getting up to--
I guess 0.5 would be the
equivalent for the mean.
And then you start
going larger--
0.9, 0.99, 0.999.
In other words, you
might actually plot as--
I should have put
these on the x value--
the probability that
you would find a data
point that far away as opposed
to implied probabilities
in terms of number of
standard deviations.
So there are some
really cool variants
of these plots that
are very useful.
And I think we'll
see some of these
when we talk a little
bit about yield
and some other distributions.
AUDIENCE: I have a question?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, after
I have the q-q plots,
how can I tell the
confidence level
that I have to say whether
or not my data is normally
distributed?
PROFESSOR: So the q-q
plot does not actually
tell you confidence intervals on
either the hypothesis that it's
normally distributed
or confidence intervals
on the parameter estimate.
There are some formal
statistical tests
where you can test that
hypothesis of normality.
And essentially, you can
use those from your--
never going to hand-calculate
some of those statistics,
and then the
probability associated
with a derived statistic
associated with normality.
You'll use your statistics
package for that.
This gives you a good
visual indication.
But to actually
test, is it normal?
Or what is the probability
that the data is non-normal?
That's a different question.
And then today, we
will start talking
about confidence intervals
on the mean and the variance,
which you also would not use
the q-q norm plot to generate.
So in fact, let's get
to that because that's--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: For that plot,
can you use regression
to see how far it
is from the normal?
PROFESSOR: Well, first off,
again, if you were actually
trying to estimate the
parameters of normality,
you would just use the data
and calculate the sample mean
and sample standard deviation.
I think if you are--
essentially what you
are posing here is,
could I go in and look
at these deviations
and do some, I don't know,
sum of squared values
of those deviations?
That's actually getting
really close to calculating
a statistic.
Call it a W or some
number, a W statistic
that I would form based on sum
of squared deviations on one
of these plots or
some other-- maybe
it's a sum of absolute
distance deviations.
Now I've got a
statistic W, and that's
getting really close to the
kinds of statistical tests
that one would run to ask
the question of normality.
I don't actually know
what the formula is
used in coming up with
a W value and then what
the normality tests are.
But that's the
kernel of the idea,
is to actually
look at your data,
form an aggregate value for that
statistic, that W statistic.
So for example, if it was
sum of absolute values,
and it-- for a sample of size
50, and that W is very near 0,
then you have high
confidence that it's
a normal distribution.
But as W gets bigger,
that would seem
to indicate more
and more likelihood
that it's not normal.
And that's exactly
the kind of thing
that's going on in the formal
statistical test for normality.
So here, we've given
you a few tools
for being able to
look at the data,
get a feel for is
it normal or not.
But it hasn't
answered the question,
how come so often we're using a
normal distribution when we're
actually looking
at manufacturing
data or other kinds
of experimental data?
And a really important thing
is the following observation--
the following fact-- that
if we are forming a sum
of independent observations
of a random variable--
so x has some
underlying distribution.
And it doesn't
actually matter what
the underlying distribution is.
But I form n
independent observations
of that random variable.
And then I look at
the distribution
of the sum of x1 plus x2
plus all n random variables.
The fascinating
fact is that the sum
of independent random
variables tends
towards a normal distribution.
This is the central
limit theorem.
So here's a neat little example.
If my underlying distribution
is in fact something
like a uniform distribution,
and if I'm, say,
pulling off 20 samples of
x1 and 20 samples of x2
from a different
uniform distribution,
and I form, say,
100 samples of, I
guess, 100 sets-- each
one of these is, I guess,
1,000 points in this example.
But I essentially
take the sum of all
of these random variables and
form a new random variable.
The new random variable tends
towards a normal distribution
with some mean and variance.
Some of you I saw in 2853.
And I had a nice
link to a website.
And I'll actually dig that up
and post it for this class.
It's the SticiGui website.
It's a statistics--
interactive statistic
package out of UC Berkeley.
And it's really fun.
You can actually
form these kinds
of sums of random variables
out of different underlying
distributions and
plot them and start
to see how close the sum
or the normalized sum
of these distributions
are to a normal.
So there's some very, very
nice interactive tools
that you can play with.
Now, an important point here is
if I'm calculating the mean--
so I'm calculating an
x bar across my data.
And I've got 100
samples, each drawn--
and I'm assuming I'm drawing
it from the same underlying
distribution,
whatever that may be.
What is the distribution
of the sample mean?
Well, if you look at the
formula for the sample mean,
it's not exactly a
sum of your data.
It's the sum of your data,
then divided by 1, right?
It's summed from i
equals 1 to whatever n
is of your individual samples.
So it is a sum, and then
with a constant out front.
But the point is, by appealing
to the central limit theorem,
the sample mean distribution,
the PDF associated
with a sample mean,
always tends towards
the normal distribution.
So we're going to come back
to this idea of sampling
and what the distribution is for
sample statistics a little bit
later.
But more generally, very
often what we're doing
is pulling data out of a process
that in itself is already,
by the physics of the
process, highly averaged.
And therefore,
it's averaging lots
of perhaps other
underlying strange physics
or difficult physics.
But in aggregate, that averaging
nature of the data itself--
not the operation
that we perform,
but each individual
underlying data point--
each individual x sub i--
underneath of that may
have some averaging
by the physics
going on that will
help to drive it towards itself
being a normal distribution.
So just to remind you,
the central limit theorem
is probably the most used and
perhaps often abused appeal
to why we're using normal
distributions very often.
It is still good to test it.
But there is a good reason why
very often, our data does come
up as normal distributions.
So I want to talk
a little bit now
about sampling because
we are very often using
actual measurements and
data to try to get estimates
for, or more generally, build
a model of our random process
and estimate parameters
of that random process.
And we've said in general,
p sub x is unknown.
The data-- always plot your
raw data first and foremost.
And very often, the raw data
will suggest a distribution.
Or then histograms may
provide some insight.
So for example, a
very quick histogram
will very often give
you the difference
between a normal distribution
and a uniform distribution.
If it's evenly
falling, and I don't
have this falloff in the
tails, that's very important.
And then we can also use
things like the q-q norm plot
to test some of those things.
So the first job is to come
up with what likely [COUGH]
distribution you want to use.
Nine times out of 10,
normal distribution
will be appropriate.
And then the second
thing is to estimate
parameters of the distribution.
And the normal distribution,
again, to remind you,
just has these two
parameters, mean and variance.
And now what we want
to do is estimate them.
Now, everybody is
used to the formulas.
We've got the
formulas right here
for calculating from your
sample, your limited number
of pieces of data,
what things are--
what a few important statistics
are or characteristics
are of that data, like the
sample mean or the average,
and the sample variance.
But what I want to give you
a feel for today, perhaps
the most subtle idea,
an important idea
for interpretation, for
establishment of confidence
intervals, for actually
being able to say where
you think the real values lie--
the subtle idea is
that these themselves
are statistics that have their
own PDF, their own Probability
Density Function.
They have a sample
statistics that
fall that tell you the
likelihood of observing
particular values of them--
that establish bounds for where,
if I had a different sample,
how close you think
the new sample,
still drawn from the
underlying parent distribution,
would actually lie to
the particular sample
that I just drew.
So I'm going to explain
that in a few more
slides or several slides here.
But the key idea is it's
really easy to calculate
a couple of these moments--
the mean and the variance.
For the normal
distribution, that
tells you everything for an
estimate of your raw data.
But then I want to get
to the more subtle idea
so that we can start
talking about things
like confidence intervals.
And a simple example to give
you a little bit of a feel
for this here is if
I were to ask you
what distribution
applies to the sample
mean, where does that come from?
Where does this notion of
a distribution associated
with the sample mean arise?
So if we look at the
formula for the sample mean
and expand it out,
in some sense we've
got just a sum of
independent random variables,
like we were talking about
with the central limit theorem.
There are different
constants in here.
And in this case, for the
sample mean statistic,
all of the constants are
the same, which is just 1
over the total number of
data points or sample points
that I've got.
Now, you can go back to the
definition of expectation
that we talked about earlier
and do the expectation
operator across this
and do expectation math.
So the expectation of ax is
equal to just that constant
times the expectation of the
underlying random variable.
So the 1 over n simply
comes out to the left.
And if I were to ask, what
is the mean of the PDF
associated with x bar, it
is going to be 1 over n--
the same mean.
Now what else is
going on here is
if you look at the standard
deviation of x bar--
I hope you guys can see that.
There's a variance
of x bar in here.
So that's an x and a
bar, which I just--
the pen doesn't line up
exactly with the screen.
You can also do the
expectation operator for--
oops, not the expectation,
but the variance operator.
And if you do the mathematics
on variance of some ax,
that's equal to a squared,
the variance of the underlying
variable.
And if you follow that math
through for the definition
of x bar and relate
that to the variance
of each of these x sub i's, what
you find is that the variance--
I get an n times--
I'm summing n of these
random variables.
So I've got n times--
1 over n is the
constant in here.
So I get a 1 over n squared
times the underlying
variance of my x.
So that I get a cancellation,
and the variance then
of my x bar is just equal
to what I've shown here,
a 1 over n of the variance of
the underlying distribution.
So what's interesting
here is if I start
to ask about the
distributions associated
with what are the
mean and the variance
of the normal distribution
associated with x bar--
what is the mean of an x
bar that I would typically
observe from lots of samples
of my underlying distribution?
What is a variance
I would observe?
It's related to the
underlying distribution,
but it's not exactly the same.
I've got a new random
variable, an x bar,
that has a different
mean and variance.
It's got the same
mean in this case,
but the variance
is actually scaled.
And this is extremely
useful because the variance
of my averaging means
that I'm getting a tighter
distribution--
a narrower or smaller
variance compared
to the underlying distribution.
I'm going to show you
that in a little bit more
of a graphical fashion a little
bit later because this is--
that's a preview to this
whole idea of sampling,
which is really critical.
We've already talked about this.
So the key thing here is to
get to this notion of sampling
distributions, what are the
key distributions arising
from the fact that I'm drawing
multiple pieces of data
from a parent
distribution, and then
calculating things about that?
So we'll get to some of
these key distributions
besides the normal distribution.
We'll actually talk
about these next class.
But what we want to do is go
back and get a little bit more
feel for not only the
normal distribution,
but a few other
distributions that
often arise in manufacturing,
and then also start
talking about these notions of
where the data actually lies.
What are the probabilities of
data falling out in the tails?
And using that then
to start to get
towards the idea of building
confidence intervals
and where we think the real
mean of our underlying parent
distribution sits.
Next class, we'll also
get to hypotheses tests,
which arise naturally
and actually start
to get really close to
statistical process control
charting, which is one
of the fundamental tools
of manufacturing control.
So what I'm going to
do here is go back--
this is the plan for the next--
the rest of today and
starting into tomorrow.
We're going to go
back, just remind you
of some of the discrete
variable distributions,
then talk about some of the--
which are more applicable to
attribute modeling or yield
modeling, sort of
discrete things.
Then we'll come back
and talk a little bit
about the continuous
distributions,
and then also touch
on how you manipulate
some of these distributions.
Discrete distributions-- people
seen the Bernoulli distribution
before?
Good.
This is like the
simplest distribution--
the very simplest.
You do a trial.
You do an experiment.
Can only have two outcomes,
success or failure.
You get to label
what success is.
We'll label a success
with the random variable
taking on the value of 1
and failure taking on 0.
I could flip that.
You can start to see already
a little bit of inkling
of yield in here.
Does the thing work or not?
The very simplest,
coarsest, crudest kind
of model for functionality, and
the probability or statistics
associated with that is,
does the thing work or not?
And often, we talk about
what is the probability
that the thing is functioning
at the end of the line?
Maybe that's 0.95.
So 95% of the time, I think
I've got yielding parts out.
For any one experiment,
one outcome,
I've simply got a p and 1
minus p probability associated
with that.
And the PDF can be
expressed as shown here.
Now we can go in and use
our expectation operations
for discrete random
variables and calculate what
the mean and the variance are.
And those have nice,
closed form functions
for those two outcomes.
So that's the Bernoulli.
Now the second easiest--
although it can
actually look a little
confusing at first glance.
But the second
easiest distribution
is the binomial
distribution because it's
saying that I'm simply
taking that success
or failure with a
fixed probability p
and running repeated
trials of that.
So now I'm flipping my
coin, say, which has--
perhaps it's a weighted
coin, and it comes up
heads with probability
p that's not 0.5.
Maybe it's 0.9.
But now I'm doing
that repeated times.
I'm doing that n times.
Now what's the probability
of having n successes?
Or let me state that again.
What's the probability
of having x successes
when I ran n repeated trials?
So n is the number of trials.
So if I ran 100
trials, the probability
that I had exactly x
equals to 7 successes
is given by this formula, here.
And you can actually see
this lurking in here.
How do I have 7 successes?
Well, that meant
p, the probability
of having a success, had
to come up exactly 7 times.
And the rest of the times--
if I was running 100
trials, the other 93 trials
all had to be failures.
So I've simply got the product
of all of those probabilities.
And then we've got
the combinatorics,
the n choose x, which tells me
how many different orderings
could have occurred by which
I would get the 7 successes
and 93 failures
for n equals 100.
So that's simply the different
numbers of combinations
that can come up with that.
So the notation here, by the
way, that we would often use--
and I already snuck it
in some other places--
is this little tilde
symbol here we're
using to read as "is distributed
as some distribution."
And I'm using the big B
to indicate the binomial
distribution, which
has associated with it
the underlying
Bernoulli probability--
success for any one trial--
and then the number
of repeated trials.
So this is a
discrete probability.
What's the probability
that x could take on 0.7?
0, right?
It's the number of
successes out of this.
And here are some examples
that just give you
a little bit of a feel
for what the Bernoulli
distribution looks like.
This is the number
of successes plotted
as a histogram for some values.
I think that this is--
if you try it, I think
this is a live spreadsheet.
So actually, if you double-click
on this from your PowerPoint,
it may bring up the
underlying Excel spreadsheet.
So you can actually play with
some of the parameters in this.
I don't remember what
either p or n was for this.
But you can start to
see, it's really--
it does not look quite normal
because you can never have
negative numbers of successes.
It's always truncated.
And you get these
very non-normal kinds
of distributions.
This is a binomial distribution.
But its location and its
shape can change somewhat
as you play with p and n.
By the way, up here-- this is
just the cumulative probability
function, just saying
the probability
that I've got x less than
or equal to some value.
So that's also shown.
So then this is also in
this histogram, normalized
to the fraction of products.
And so now, you can start
to look at calculating.
If this were my
data, and I simply--
it was actually
coming from a line
where I was looking at the
probability of any one part
succeeding or not, I could
start to ask questions
about the probability of
seeing, out of 1,000 products
coming off the line,
some number of defects
or some number of
failed products.
You can appeal to the binomial
distribution for that.
Now this is all still
pretty coarse, right?
It's just a very
simplified model--
failure or success for yield.
Now another discrete
distribution
is a Poisson distribution
or also sometimes referred
to as an exponential
distribution,
although terminology
there sometimes varies,
depending on whether people
are including this component
or not.
But the formal definition
for the Poisson distribution
is shown here.
Now it continues to be
a discrete distribution.
So I'm asking, what is
the probability associated
with observing x taking on
actual discrete integer values?
But this is a very nice
distribution associated with
kinds of operations that many
of you saw in 2.850 or 2.8--
yeah, 2.853.
The arrival times
in queuing networks
will often be
Poisson distributed.
But it also can come
up when we are dealing
with very large
numbers associated
with the binomial distribution
as a very good approximation
to the binomial.
And this turns out
to be really nice,
because if you actually go
back to the binomial formula
and try to calculate it for
situations where, say, n
or x are very, very
large, or p or 1 minus
p is very, very
small or very large,
very close to either
0 or 1, you end up
with some problems,
some numerical problems.
Because if you actually try to
calculate it for, let's say,
p is equal to 0.0001, or maybe
1 minus p is equal to that.
Let's say you had really,
really high yield.
And I take that, so
if that's 1 minus p--
and I'm doing this for a
sample of size a million.
I've got 0.0001 to the
one millionth power.
And numerically, you
start losing the digits.
You can't hardly
keep track of that.
But I might be asking,
what is the probability
of some substantial
number of failures?
And this, the
combinatorics, end up
being a really,
really large number.
So overall, the
overall probability
of seeing 10 failures
out of a million parts
might be substantial.
But to calculate it, you
can't do it numerically,
because I've got a huge number
times a really small number.
I get overflow or underflow.
And I can't actually
calculate it.
What's useful is in those
kinds of situations, where,
say, n and p together-- the
product of those things--
are reasonable-size
numbers, then
the Poisson distribution is a
very, very good approximation.
And this applies to things
where you have very, say,
low probability.
So p might be very small.
But I'm asking-- or I have
many, many opportunities
to observe that very
low-likelihood event.
So an example here that comes up
in semiconductor manufacturing
are things like the probability
of observing some number
of defects on a wafer.
The likelihood of seeing a
point defect on any one location
is very, very, very small.
But I've got lots
and lots of area
on the wafer-- lots
and lots of opportunity
for the appearance
of that small defect.
And so you can start to
talk about the product
of those things or
a rate per unit area
that starts to
become reasonable.
Another example is the number of
misprints on a page of a book.
You don't expect for
any one character
on a book for that to
actually be a misprint.
But over the entire aggregate
number of pages in your book,
you expect some
number of misprints.
And the statistics
that go with that
are typically
Poisson distributed.
And I already mentioned that
the mean and the variance,
if you actually apply those
formulas to this distribution,
come out to the
fascinating fact that they
are numerically the same value.
By the way, units-wise,
they're not.
But x is an integer and--
oops.
That should be x, by the way.
Come on.
Cut that out.
There we go.
So here are some example
Poisson distributions.
You can start to see one
here for a mean of 5.
It looks close to the
binomial distribution
that I showed you earlier.
And then as the mean
here is increasing,
and the lambda
parameter, you can
start to see this distribution
shifting to the right.
We said lambda is the mean.
It's also a characteristic
of the variance.
The variance is also
equal to lambda.
So that will also broaden
out for larger numbers of--
or larger values of lambda.
There's another observation
in here which is useful.
What are they starting to
look like for large lambdas?
AUDIENCE: Normal.
PROFESSOR: Normal, right.
If you looked at that, it
doesn't look very normal
distributed.
It's truncated.
It's a little bit skewed.
But another approximation is for
large lambda, that also tends
towards a normal distribution.
So very often, you've got
this success or succession
of approximations, where
you might take a binomial,
approximate it as a Poisson.
But then for large numbers,
a normal distribution also
can be a useful approximation.
So let's go back to the
continuous distributions,
the normal and the uniform.
And here, I want to start
getting to actually how you use
or calculate probabilities of
observations in certain ranges
and in particular things, like
the probabilities of observing
things out in the tails.
So here's a continuous
distribution
that has a probability
density function.
This is the normal--
excuse me, the
uniform distribution
that has the same probability
density for values
in some range.
And then I've also
indicated with a capital F
our cumulative density
function for that.
So this is just reminding you of
a little bit of the terminology
there.
But I'm highlighting
the uniform distribution
because there's a couple
of very standard questions,
that if you have a
known PDF or CDF,
these are the kinds of questions
that you're going to be asking
again and again and again.
And they're nice
and intuitive off
of the uniform distribution.
When we get to the normal
and other distributions,
they're not quite as intuitive.
But seeing them here for the
uniform first, I think, helps.
One of the typical
kinds of questions
is I want to know, what is
the probability that some x is
less than or equal to some
value if I were to draw it
from this underlying
distribution--
from a normal distribution?
And so one could ask
that using either
the PDF or the Cumulative
Density Function.
And sometimes, one or
the other, if they're
tabulated or available
to you, is easier to use.
Clearly, if this is a
Probability Density Function
here, I can ask it in terms
of the interval question.
Oops, excuse me-- the interval
question right here, and say,
well, the probability that x is
less than or equal to that x1
is simply the integration
up of that probability.
And you can do that
numerically or just
by hand on such a
simple distribution.
But the point that is actually
exactly the value that
is tabulated on the
Cumulative Density Function.
That's the definition of the
So if you've got the CDF, you
simply look it up and say,
what is f of x1 equal to
whatever your value is
for that probability function?
Now similarly, you can
also ask the question,
what is the probability that
x sits within some range,
say, between x1 and x2?
And again, you
can do that either
off of the underlying
density function, just
integrating and
saying, yes, x has
to lie between those values,
and integrate up the density.
Or you can recognize that
the probability that x
is less than x2 is
simply that value
and subtract off that
the probability that x
was less than x1 is that.
And so therefore, the
difference between those two
corresponds to the integration
on the underlying Probability
Density Function.
So that's pretty easy.
That should be pretty clear.
Let's talk about that also
for the normal distribution
because some of
those values are not
as easy to integrate up by hand.
In fact, there exist no
closed-form formulas.
But they are tabulated for you.
And that's where
going to the table
on the normal distribution
for things like f of x
are going to--
is an operation that you will
actually perform quite a bit
when you're manipulating
normal distributions.
So here's another plot.
We've already talked, or I've
shown other examples here
of the normal distribution.
I've tagged off on
this plot for us
a few useful little numbers
to have as rules of thumb.
This is actually, I think,
a moderately useful page
to print out and have off
on the side for your use.
In particular, what
I'm showing here
is for the normal distribution
you've got a formula.
You're hardly ever
going to actually plug
in values for the formula.
But if you look out plus
1 standard deviation,
plus 2 standard
deviation, on the PDF,
I've tried to indicate
here how rapidly
the value of that probability
density falls off.
So for example, one standard
deviation, I'm about 60%
the peak.
Two standard deviations,
I'm down to about 13.5%
of the peak.
Now more often than asking what
is the relative probabilities
of these things, you're actually
more often asking, what is--
how much-- what is the
integrated probability
density of the random
variable out in some tail
or in some central region?
And that's where the Cumulative
Density Function is really
the one that you want to use.
And so what I'm showing
here is out for some number
of standard deviations-- this is
mu minus 3 standard deviation.
This is saying the
probability that x is less
than mu minus 3 sigma
is exactly that value.
That equals f of
mi minus 3 sigma.
And I simply look that up.
And that's about 0.00135, or
less than 0.1% of your data
should fall less than 3
sigma off the left side
of your distribution.
And then I've tabulated that
for two standard deviations, one
standard deviation.
By the way, what's
the probability, now
that I've marked it up,
that your data falls less
than your mean?
50%.
It's a symmetric distribution.
And so, in fact, you
could then ask also
the question, what's the
probability that my data is
all the way from my left tail
up to two standard deviations
above the mean?
And that's 97.7%.
But I want to also
point out these--
this distribution itself is also
anti-symmetric around the mean.
So this value and
this value sum to 1.
So in other words,
1 minus whatever
is out in the upper tail
is equal to the probability
of being below the lower tail.
So what's tabulated is
not mu minus numbers
of standard deviations.
But what will often--
what is actually tabulated
are the standardized or unit
normal distribution-- again,
the mean-centered version,
where I subtract off
the mean and divide
by the standard deviation.
And that gives a PDF and
a CDF that is universal.
And that is what will
often be then tabulated
as the unit normal
Cumulative Density Function.
In some sense, that's what I
actually showed on this plot,
by just labeling it as a
function of mu and standard
deviations.
But now when you normalize,
that becomes in units of z as 0
and the numbers of standard
deviations off on the side.
Now, if you look at
the back of Montgomery,
there is a whole
bunch of these tables.
And you'll be using these tables
in some of the problem sets
and so on.
And there is a table
for the unit normal.
And in particular,
what's tabulated
is this Cumulative Density
Function for the unit normal.
And we have a little
bit of terminology
here that I want
to alert you to,
because we often talk
about percentage points off
of some distribution or
percentage points of the unit
normal, as pictured here.
And what we're talking about
is relating percentages
of my distribution that are
in some location, usually
the tails, to numbers
of standard deviations
that I have to go in order
to apportion that amount over
in the tails or in
the central regions.
So a very typical question I
might ask is, how many z's--
how many "unit standard
deviations," how many z's--
do I have to go
away from the mean
in order to get some
alpha or some percentage
of the distribution
located out in those tails?
So for example, I
might say I want
the 20%, 20th
percentile percentage
point, the 0.2 probability that
my data sits in the two tails.
So for a total probability that
all my data or the remain--
the portion of my
data is on either
of the tails, some further away
than some z, that means 10%
is in each of the tails.
And I'm asking the
question, how far--
how many standard
deviations do I
have to go to get
10% in the left tail
and 10% out in the right tail?
So I'm essentially
asking the question,
what is the probability
on the cumulative unit
normal Probability Distribution
Function to get to--
how many z's do I
have to go to get
to half of that
alpha probability
being in each of the tails?
One observation here is that
these things are, again,
anti-symmetric.
So I can also ask the
question either looking
just the right tail
or the left tail.
And then you can do the inverse
operation using the table.
So I'm actually asking
the question, what
is the z associated with that?
And I'm looking up on this plot.
So I might ask, OK, I need
10% there in the tail.
How many z's does
that correspond to?
And to get 10% out
in that left tail,
I got to go out 1.28 standard
deviations off to the left.
That's the operation that one
would look up in the table.
So very often, you would get
to these kinds of lookups,
where you're relating the
probability alpha of your data
lying below that number
of standard deviations
and what that corresponding
standard deviation is.
So I didn't copy one of the
tables out of Montgomery,
but you'll get some practice
with that on the problem sets.
Now, there's other
related operations
you can do once you have that.
So for example, now I can
ask, what is the probability
not just that data
lies out in the tail,
but what are the probabilities
that it also or instead lies
in the middle region?
They're all the same
kinds of operations.
And so for example,
here's a quick tabulation
for three different
kinds of examples,
where I'm asking not
what is out in the tails,
but I'm asking what is within
the center plus/minus 1 sigma
region of the data?
And if you look
very carefully, I'm
using exactly these
Cumulative Probability Density
functions for the unit normal.
This is for a unit normal.
And looking out, what's
the cumulative probability
over in the left tail?
The right tail?
Doing those observations.
But these are also very
nice rules of thumb
to have ready for you, which
is saying within plus/minus 1
standard deviation in the
normal, 68% of your data
is going to fall in
that 1 sigma region.
In the case of if I
expand out to 2 sigma,
now I've got 95% of my data
should fall roughly in there.
And if I expand out even
further to the 3 sigma,
that's the 99.7% of your
data would be falling--
should fall within those center
three standard deviations.
So the percentage
points out there,
the part that falls outside
of that, is about 3 and a--
3 and 1,000.
We'll come back to this when we
see statistical process control
and control charts because you
may have run into these control
charts.
We're often plotting the
3 sigma control limits.
And essentially
what we're saying
is only a very small
fraction of my data--
3 out of 1,000, if
I'm using plus/minus
3 sigma control limits.
3 out of 1,000 points of
my data, by random chance
alone, should be falling
outside of those 3 sigma bounds.
So that starts to get as close
to statistical process control.
So what we're going
to do next time
is start to look a little bit
more closely at statistics.
When I do form, again,
things like the sample
mean, or I form the sample
standard deviation or sample
variance from my
data, those themselves
have these probability
densities associated with them.
And from that, we're going
to be able to go backwards
and essentially work to
try to understand things
about the underlying process
distribution, the parent
probability distribution
function, associated with that.
So we're going to
have to understand
more complicated PDFs than
the normal distribution
because things like
the sample variance
is not going to be
normally distributed.
It's going to have its
own bizarre distribution--
in this case, the
chi-square distribution.
So we'll return to looking at
some additional distributions,
but these same manipulations
will come up again.
And what we're ultimately going
to want to be able to do is
make inferences about the
underlying distribution--
the parent process--
what its mean is,
what its variance is,
based on the calculated sample
mean and sample variance
that we might be using,
and then also make
inferences about the
likelihood that the true mean
lies in certain ranges.
Or to put it another
way, next time,
we'll also be talking
about confidence intervals.
So we'll see you on Thursday.
Watch for the message from
Hayden about tours and enjoy.